hey welcome everybody so this is the the
graduation ceremony for the for the
professional programs first professional
programs in the Graduate School of
Architecture planning preservation and
whatever which is to say the school that
thinks of every single aspect of the
built environment as possibly needing
our attention right so we're really and
and how do you dig a distinction between
the built environment and the
environment while you can so actually
it's the sort of school devoted to the
planet if you think about it so it
really is in a certain sense a very very
ambitious place that's trying to think
about the future of the kind of global
situation and trying to do so with kind
of real creativity and real experience
you're a little different than the
people that we celebrated in the
previous situation and the previous
situation you've got these hotshots that
fly into the school at high speed and
fly out at high speed and all you feel
is the sort of turbulence that they
create within the school but that
turbulence is also something that
contributes to your education because
you're here for one two and three years
or two years like different rhythm so
you get sort of affected by their
turbulence but also you get in there
away in other words they're going very
fast and they basically bang into you
because you're coming up and then you
hit together so what happens is two
different kinds of species interact and
the collision between you is so powerful
that afterwards nobody can remember who
came in Fast and who came in slow and
then you sort of all leave together but
I do think that in the end even though
we no longer can tell the difference
between your work and the work of the
post professional programs it's still a
different threshold for you because you
are with us for longer and it's
therefore a different threshold for us
because we know you much better and we
are Believe It or Not sadder about you
leaving than anyone else you come to us
from about 65 different countries and
then use maybe you hang around New York
for a while and then you return usually
to where you came from so in theory we
are supposed to be educating you but in
practice you educate us and meantime you
educate each other and we just pretend
to be here more or less intelligently
watching the future of the planet are
evolved so you're on this threshold and
you're about to leave but the point I
want to make to you is that the school
is absolutely not the same as the school
you first arrived in because even if
that building was designed in 1911 and
even if it's supposed to tell the world
that everything is fixed and stable and
everything goes back to cosmological
truths and proportions and so on inside
that building it's totally crazy and
there's so much energy inside that
building that actually the whole
building moves it's a kind of a ship you
get into the ship and it goes somewhere
and you are the people who have actually
made the ship move it's super exciting
that we don't know where it's going we
don't know why we don't even know what
architecture is right I keep telling you
that that we don't know I think finally
now that you're graduating you realize
that none of us know but it is the
question we always always ask ourselves
what it is this build environment that
we take care of and precisely because we
don't know what it is we love it we
really love it because it's full of all
this mystery and all of our expertise is
applied to them so I think the main
purpose of the school is to generate new
kinds of questions we hate answers we
get answers very fast and we use answers
as ways to get towards questions and you
have asked questions of us continuously
during your time here I mean architects
and planners and urban designer stand
preservationist sand all of the above
and all that will be added to that our
experts in thinking differently about a
world that all of us take for granted
for most people the built environment is
a steady more or less reliable situation
around which everything else is in flux
for the architect the plan of the
preservationist and the designer the
built environment itself is what is in
flux is in change
so we're kind of experts in seeing how
solid objects actually can move and can
move people so it's an incredibly
exciting thing to do to be your teachers
to be with you to be thinking together
about the future of the built
environment we absolutely have no idea
about the best possible future for the
built environment we really don't we
have the best library in the world we
have the best memory of what have been
the best ideas of the future we have a
pretty good idea of what is the best
current work of today and you can see it
in the end of your exhibition but where
that is going is absolutely unclear so
the way this school works is to assume
that you as the graduating students will
be the ones that decide the future of
the build environment it will not be the
school that will not be the scholars it
will not be the great teachers it will
not be the great figures of today it
would be another generation that will
emerge around about 10 years from now
about 10 years from now the meaning of
what you have done here starts to become
visible even if 10 years from now you
reject everything you have learned here
as inadequate that's the moment in which
the education tax starts to sort of take
effect so what happens in this school
it's so hard core in its experimental
mission that the whole thing depends on
a kind of a trust a really good teacher
trusts that the student is ultimately
better than the teacher a terribly weak
teacher is one who is sure that he or
she is more informed is more in control
than the student the real teacher is the
one that imagines that something is
going to happen with that student
something amazing is going to happen ten
years from now and that that thing will
happen will make the teacher look stupid
so the primary mission of the faculty
that G sub is to create the conditions
for you to demonstrate that they are
stupid right and if you're a really good
student you demonstrate that before
leaving the school right just at the
last second early on at the school
you're like our great teachers I could
learn something from them halfway
through the school I'm not sure they
have that much to teach me final part of
the school you just leave them behind
you go through and the slipstream and
fly for and say look you're an old
technology like I don't have time I
can't wait for you things have to be
done in the world so essentially this
threshold that you're on as a threshold
when you've actually already left your
teachers behind you symbolically now
leave the school behind but something
will happen about 10 years from now so
in other words what we do when we are
teaching you is we take care of
something that has not happened yet it's
kind of like a science fiction story of
how do you how do you nurture something
an event that will happen 10 years from
now how do you create and shape
something whose whose whose meaning it
will not be clear foot foot to foot in
years in a certain sense what you do is
you work on a kind of instinct that that
something is happening between you and
the student and not quite knowing what
that thing is that magical thing it will
grow it will become amazing in the
future in other words a really good
school finds the kind of teacher that
can help students to develop new ways of
thinking that will only really be
applied under very very new conditions
that will require even further changes
in thinking in other words we have to
draw on everything we know about the
built environment to put you at the very
limit of the knowledge of the field so
that you will then jump way beyond that
limit and change the very meaning of the
field when we say Graduate School of
Architecture planning and preservation
we do not know what that means we really
don't we're a school devoted to what
that might mean 10 years from now which
means we don't train professionals in
each of these fields we train the
possibility of an entirely new
generation and a new type of
professional in a way we care not about
the shape of buildings or the shape of
plans or the shape of a preservation
project we care about the shape of the
professional the shape of the architect
the shape of the urban errs the shape of
the plan are the shape of the
preservationist in the shape of the real
estate developer in other words where we
are really experimental is with the kind
of professional intelligence for that
reason the school is a la
our tree as you know it's a hard core 24
hours constant all year-round laboratory
devoted to experimental ideas about the
possible future of designers in society
this class is particularly unique if
this was a you know if we were dealing
with wine we would be saying this is an
incredibly good year the thing about
wine is you don't know if it's good to
drink one year from now two years from
now three years from now you can have
very good grapes but still not know when
they're perfect we know that you are an
amazing group we know that this is a
year that will be remembered somebody at
some point will remember or try to
figure out what it is about this group
in 2009 that was very very different
from 2008 I have some ideas about that
for example we're supposed to be in a
time of crisis and that's a time in
which the very very first thing that
happens is that all of you are out of
work instantly actually before there's a
crisis architects and urban s and
preservationists are out of work that's
the first sign right and yet the most
optimistic and most intelligent thoughts
come from those very people in other
words the crisis so-called crisis is
actually the great time for reflection
and if the purpose of a school is to
reflect upon the future meaning of the
built environment and a future kind of
society actually the crisis is the
moment of our greatest responsibility
and our greatest intelligence when the
global markets are going up everybody's
busy there are plans preservation jobs
architects have commissions things are
being built nobody has time for thinking
what you do is you find a niche market
and you ride the market to its future
the moment the market crashes everybody
tries for the first time to understand
what's happening meanwhile whether the
market goes up well the market goes down
this school is thinking thinking
thinking thinking and so when the market
drops suddenly our thoughts become very
very visible and people look to the
school for some kind of leadership and
that leadership will come from you
because you basically enter the supposed
crisis with an entirely new mental set I
actually think that precisely because
this generation of students working in
this generation of our school is devoted
to
testing the limits of the field in other
words we keep putting pressure on the
definition of the field it's for that
reason that I think you will play a
crucial leadership role in this moment
in time in which the whole question of
professional expertise is is up in the
air and here's the hypothesis about what
makes your generation different I
believe that you might well be the first
generation from this school that refuses
to accept compromise and i'll tell you
what i mean by that of course everybody
says that you're going to have these
amazingly beautiful ideas in school and
then when you go out into the world the
world is going to erode them down and
they're going to value engineer
everything out of your brilliance so you
have to aim very high and then the world
will erode it down from amazing to still
very good so there's this general
perception that the world is going to
erode the brilliance of your ideas but
you are so hot and so fast that it
really doesn't matter you'll still do
amazing things but that sense that there
will be some kind of compromise is
refused by your generation I think you
are the first generation that doesn't
assume that if you go for example for an
ethical position you can't at the same
time be making money as a professional
there's a it's the first time you can be
responsible with energy that you can
develop energy responsible solutions and
also work as an artist's in other words
all the traditional choices that
designers used to face you don't accept
them you're kind of Swiss Army knife
personalities you're multitasking multi
channeling there's not a single source
of information you won't use there's not
a single technology you won't devote and
you just assume that if you put those
things in the right combination you can
address any problem according to any
system that represents in my opinion a
whole new level of intelligence to the
field you are undoubtedly a superior
technology you're as annoying as hell
right it's very very irritating to be
with people who simply by enjoying their
life reveal the fact that you're an old
technology right the inability of the
faculty to fully absorb the complexity
and the questions that you are asking is
we are as it were put into wheelchairs
by your brilliance it's incredibly
annoying but
this moment when you go out into the
school we suddenly flip from being
annoyed feeling redundant filling out a
touch to feeling an unbelievably proud
and wanting to claim some kind of credit
for this new superior technology so I'm
just trying to tell you in a long winded
way that the school is amazingly proud
of this particular year super super
proud and there is a kind of a
conspiracy theory here we think you're
going to do real damage in the world we
really think that the world is not
equipped to handle you we were not
equipped the world was not equipped so
we have the secret feeling that two or
three or four or five years from now the
landscape of our field will be
profoundly changed and it will be your
generation that's at the forefront for
that so it's amazingly exciting moment I
believe we're witnessing the birth of a
new generation of thinking you might say
oh yeah but then they say that sort of
thing every year isn't every year like
the new brilliant future and so on yes
to a certain extent but then there is a
moment in which you realize that the
most hardcore ambitions of a school are
actually being represented by the
quality of the students and the proof of
that was when the faculty had to get
together and try to figure out which of
you to give prizes to and there was
never ever a battle as strong as the one
that was fought over these students and
that for us demonstrates we are dealing
with a whole new generation this is a
superior generation you are infinitely
better than the school in which you're
about to leave you have given the school
great respect and honor by treating the
laboratory space as a serious space to
test out some of the most important
ideas that you have much much more
importantly lurking somewhere is our new
ideas that are so new that they could
not even be understood as ideas within
the context of even this amazingly
experimental environment so I think the
laboratory tests that you were doing
there is in this moment of history no
longer a very very solid wall between
the inside of the laboratory which is
the school and the outside which is the
world which is changing as fast as any
laboratory in this moment of history the
real competition for the school is
absolutely not other schools the real
competition is India China
America Africa Russia New Orleans in
other words the world itself is
undergoing absolutely radical
transformation and our profession simply
do not have the skillsets appropriate to
that you the amazingly superior and
annoying generation of super students
are the ones that are appropriately
ready to assess these kinds of questions
it's really the first global generation
it's the first generation that uses a
kind of global intelligence it's the
first generation that can demonstrate
that everybody around you is is lucky to
have your care and your respect we were
the lucky ones for the time that you
were with us I think the world is going
to be super lucky but you're also going
to rearrange things you're going to
rearrange things a lot in theory you're
going to do work that's so amazing that
Avery library is going to collect it
that you're going to send these ideas
out into the world and they're going to
come back to the library frankly Avery
library does not have a classification
system that can accommodate your work we
will work hard while you work hard in
the world so that when your work is
acknowledged and recognized we would be
able to bring it back into the school
and honor it but I'm being honest to you
we at this moment do not have the way to
classify your work it's that good so
it's an amazing class do damage you are
the class of 2009 amazing close
not since the 1960's has there been this
combination of ethical and ecological
and political commitment from students
absolutely synchronized with the latest
ideas and the latest technology and the
latest systems of communication that's
the combination that you represent
amazing okay we give degrees or not
let's give to ease Lori Hawkinson
professor Hawkinson who's director of
the advanced studios in the amazing
sequence of programs is going to read
out the graduates from the master of
architecture program okay ready guys
made it okay Brian Frederick acne
Zachary Michael aiders
Christopher Philip barley
Otis George Birkin
Bridget Marie borders
samuel james rosette
Marlo marine Brown
michael david Cavender
Michelle I Chang
lu yu chen
you suck Choi
michael j h ow
egbert miles to
Zachary deed Kolbert
Michael Paul contento
Aaron Vedas Davis
Brett Rebecca Dorfman
rachet Lynn Espinosa
jin bo Yin
Priscilla mcmillan love it Frasier
stephen daniel garcia
samuel john Grenadier
Greta Murray handsome
jinwu yo
Edgar forest Jesse
Emily Brooke Johnson
henna Kapoor
William Potter Kemper
Sharif Kabir college a
Daniel Jackson kid
G hi Kim
John so Kim
young Jake him
Raina leak him
Sharon me and Kim
young go cook
Karen L khoobi
sung yong li
young Julie
Philip tinggi Lynn
Brian George Manning spin
Andrew Seth McDowell
Joseph Vincent McGrath
Leah mica my stolen
Clinton at Lee Miller
Jeffrey mark millet
do you know
eun jin park
Daniel Jordan pain
Julie Mei Lin Ping
sharone Dina p on kowski Olivia Ramos
Benjamin Douglas right
Deborah Ashley Richards
Dahlia the Jamila Roberts
William West Road eager Robinette
I all arrests yes Rosen
Christian Marcus rude
Daniel Christophe Rizzo
Lawrence Dominic Sarah's on Elizabeth
Lane sharer
Lindsay Brenna Sherman
catherine marie kashima
Matthew Austin stout
mateus nikodem tarsan ski
Troy Conrad thearon
John William tequila
matthew john Voss
and Miriam near award congratulations
those are the architects of the future
from 2009
so now we're going to give the degrees
to the graduates of the urban planning
program and its director is Professor
Robert Beauregard who is just an amazing
colleague a great leader a visionary and
is really bringing a whole new sense of
vision to the planning program and if
you if you are reading the newspaper if
you're looking at the internet and
you're listening to the news what you're
hearing about is planning planning is
basically as hot as can possibly be
planning's had to give up its idea of
being kind of thoughtful and reflective
and time-based and has heads now to be
thoughtful and urgently apply this is a
program absolutely in action and Bob's
credit to make an amazing program and
amazing set of graduates
Katherine bonds de moto
Thomas Bassett
Daniel Haynes burger
James Steven Cox
Kyle Robert Stuart Daniels theresa marie
d de Brian David Gardner
stefanie lynn Gary Chelsea Lauren blease
Catalina Anna grubber which hall Naomi
her son rings cog catherine kim
in baku Shoni
Michael Aaron khobor
Casey Elizabeth Laflamme
Anna 20 land Eileen Kai yuan liang
stephane de yen limb
Katherine Jane lepak e g'wan Lou
andreea Victoria melero column inna
he sucked Park
sun mon POC
abdul saboor
sad omitsu sakaguchi
matthew evans schwartz
young n say ow
gingy Shem
pretty casati
Patrick Norman Streeter
un Tong
Jessica Suzanne vanhouten linjiang
so what do you think this is the urban
planners of the future from the class of
so I want to introduce you to the
miraculous elegant refined professor
andrew dhaka recently granted tenure at
columbia university and the brilliant
brilliant leader of the preservation
program and i'm thrilled to graduate the
following people alania helen becker
Matthew oh and cootie
Brett Rebecca Dorfman
eggs oooo Shekhar Leanne flandreau
Julie Laura foster
Christine ha
negin Malachy
minzy Karis mccook christina marie
nugent Julia hunter Palmer Tara Rashid
William fremont Peter rentals Benjamin
Joel Sabatini Mariana Judith's erongo
jennifer lynn shork Carolyn Rose
Stevenson Janine Marie Wilkos
congratulations historic preservation
okay some prizes you know what can you
say we start with the William Kenny
fellows Memorial traveling prizes super
interesting because students make a
proposal and the faculty judges the
value of the proposal without knowing
where it's coming from who it's coming
from so this is really a proposal about
ideas and if you listen to the names of
these projects you can hear where this
generation is thinking and where it
thinks the kind of key acupuncture
points are for research so firstly
coming from the architecture
subcommittee for a project called
finding a balance between vernacular
architecture and developing building
practices in Bhutan Katy Shima and Megan
Quinn
for a project entitled the future of the
medina negotiating modernization and
gentrification through comparative
studies in North Africa Emily Johnson
and Deborah Richards
for a project entitled transnational
network urban development along the
trans-siberian railway Greta handsome
for a project called amphibious adaption
architecture in the response to rising
water Daniel Kidd
for project entitled the architecture of
social capital Bridget borders and
forest Jessie
for project entitled suburban
alternatives innovative low-rise
high-density housing of northern and
western Europe current khoobi
and a project called this is later the
fate of urban isms in the postcondition
aarondavid and layer mysoline
from the historic preservation program
the subcommittee has awarded to kennys
the first is for a project entitled
documenting Silk Road structures in the
sorry i caress step will rain it's
and for a project called documenting
juke joints Elena Becker Janine Wilkos
and shreya flandreau
okay from the urban planning
sub-committee one of them is going to a
project entitled the city is a skatepark
Los Angeles how planning practices
addresses skateboarding Los Angeles
praetor Saudi
scandinavians sustainability a
neighborhood level approach to carbon
emission reductions brian gardner
a project entitled learning from abroad
creative uses of walls and roof tops in
European cities nyomi person rings go
and now for the school-wide kinney
Awards which are just across the board
amazing a project again of such
creativity in such brilliance the first
of which is called lightweight thin
short construction and the preservation
of public space this is a project from
Hunter Palmer and Tara Rashid
a project entitled the production of
perception asymmetrical study of Libya
Troy Connor alderman and Chris Bailey
and now a project entitled walking
architecture hiking the router /
greenough the pilgrims route this is a
project from william road eager
Robinette
and now a prize for the project entitled
transnational izing TransMilenio
bringing better us rep but better bus
rapid transit from Colombia to the
United States and drama pillar okala
Mena and Thomas facet
okay now a project entitled imagining
Sarajevo tracing post-war architectural
visions to the realities of the present
Matthew stout
and the final school-wide kinney goes
for a project called food food for
thought Zachary Colbert and Egbert miles
chew
and now the historic preservation
program awards these are the thesis
awards firstly for the best thesis to
explore materials conservation goes to a
project advised by George wheeler a
remarkable conservation scientist for a
project entitled evaluation of the
physical and chemical properties of
dolomitic Lima de jennifer sharp
for the best thesis addressing design in
historic preservation a project advised
by John Stubbs called a future for
shorter garlo conservation planning for
historic Royal Gardens parks and
pavilions in Iran and the winner is
Negron Maliki
and now for them and now for the best
thesis addressing preservation history
and theory advisor was Thea proton and
the project was entitled a planned
community in Minneapolis how can it be
preserved and that question is asked by
Caroline Stevenson
and now for the best thesis considering
design and preservation theory it's a
project advised by Andrew Lockhart the
director of the program it's entitled
architecture and urban education reform
the significance of Harlem Public
Schools 1954 to 1970 and this is Brett
Dorfman
and the final thesis prize is the
preservation alumni's james marsden
fitch thesis prize james marsden fetch
of course founding the program more or
less in 1964 the oldest historic
preservation program in the world so
this is a name with great honor and
dignity this thesis prize goes to a
project advised by andrew dahl cart
called the bush terminal model laughs
and early reinforced concrete buildings
on Brooklyn's waterfront they
significance as industrial heritage by
Christine who
and now the most important award the
historic preservations student peer to
peer award the toughest one to win this
is awarded to the student whose wild
participation in preservation has earned
the respect of the whole student body
the wildest most respected student is
Jennifer short
okay now for the urban planning program
awards first of all the Charles
Abraham's thesis award this is for a
master's thesis that best exemplifies a
commitment to social justice the winner
did a thesis entitled preserving racism
the New York City Landmarks Preservation
Commission James cuts
and now the planning challenge award for
a master's thesis that makes a
substantive contribution to our
understanding of a contemporary planning
issue for thesis entitled planning for
retail the role of New York City
Department of Planning in DCP in for
inner-city neighborhoods and Dre
Victoria my pillar alkylamino
and now for the planning research design
award this is for a thesis that
exemplifies a commitment to research
methodology and or planning techniques
pro thesis entitled the chron SE and non
miracle in China tacit relationships and
impacts on local industrial development
youngish n
and now for the American Institute of
Certified planners outstanding student
award simply for outstanding attainment
in the study of planning this award goes
to Carolina greeba vich Hall
and now the urban planning award for
high academic attainment it goes to
Patrick Streeter
and now the new york chapter of the
american planning association award for
academic excellence and leadership in
urban planning the leader academically
excellent as she is is Stephanie Lynn
Gary
and a school Service Award for
outstanding service to the school goes
to Kwan tang
and finally the student award this is
the urban planning student peer to peer
award to the student whose dedication
reliability and sheer willingness to
help others has earned the respect of
the student body SATA mitsui Sakaguchi
now the bill Center for the Study of
American architecture awards firstly the
Catherine Hoover war Sanger writing a
prize which is awarded by the temple
hoyne buell Center for the Study of
American architecture directed by Ronald
Martin for an outstanding essay on
American architecture there are two
awards the first goes to Karen khoobi
and the second goes to William roediger
Robinette
okay now from the architecture program
these are the Lucille's myzel oh and
fish memorial prizes this is simply when
the amazing studio teachers identify the
most amazing student in the most recent
of their studios this is open to a mark
students and aad students and UD
students and of course right now we're
going to do architecture the teachers
Leslie Gill and Mike Jacobs doing this
amazing studio called rates of exchange
surplus and deficit in to global
ecoregions the winner of the Lauren
frisch's Clinton Miller
from Lori Hawkin sins studio entitled
the stimulus studio new ideas on
infrastructure america for obama's
stimulus package now a studio which by
the way for of the people in that studio
recently won an award and in an amazing
competition the winners of the low and
fish two people Daniel Kidd and Zachary
Kohlberg
Keith Catherine caseman czar amazing
studio in Brazil conceicao Hill stealthy
demonstrations the winner of the low and
fish is Elizabeth Shira
steven holl continuing his sequence of
studios on the architect architectonics
of music it gets better and better and
the winner this time is a double winner
riichi Espinosa and Dahlia Roberts
for Fredrik live rats a studio called
knowledge city Abu Dhabi the winner is
yin pillion
reinhold Martin studio entitled
financial imaginaries mumbai New York
the winner of the loan fish is Otis
Birkin
Scott Marbles studio building democracy
in Bhutan the winner is hangul cook
and you've got to know it's almost
impossible to win these prizes right n
architects mini Hong and Eric banjee
gave the winner for their Manhattan
dystopia studio-2 and Rousseff McDowell
galia solomonov studio on DF distrito
federal or downtown forgotten the winner
is William Kemper
alfredo Brillon berg and who bear clump
of slum lab for their project Holland
Morocco code and counter code Emily
Johnson
and finally Michael belk's critic for
managing energy and cars and houses Sam
goo nada
okay now the student awards firstly to
the student who's ridiculous commitment
within studio and the school at large
has earned the respect of the student
body the most ridiculously committed
person is Karen khoobi
the second award goes to the student
whose work questions the standards of
architecture and promises to change the
profession which is kind of like the
mission of the school Seth McDowell
okay now the building technologies honor
award to the student who demonstrates an
ability to incorporate building
technologies into the issues of
architectural design Joseph McGrath
the visual studies Honor Award for
innovative use of computing media in
architectural or urban research design
and fabrication the winner of this is
christian rad
and now the alicia wad Malik memorial
history theory honor award and an award
in the in the memory of somebody dear to
the school and a family dear to the
school in recognition of high quality of
work in the history theory sequence
Joseph McGrath
now for school service awards for
outstanding service to the school there
are two awards Michael Chow and forest
Jesse
okay gets a little heavy at this point
the alpha alpha rho chi metal for
leadership and service to the school and
promise of professional merit Daniel
Payne
okay we come down to the 33 awards that
we're going to give building our way
towards the finish it was said several
times during the day long review of the
M arc students work that this was the
finest year's work in the history of the
school you need to know that that's not
said easily there are usually members of
the faculty who want to drag it down
literally there was the thought that
this was the best quality set of
portfolios that have been judged in the
history of the school as they say past
performance is no indication of future
performance but if it was this would be
an amazing set of people you're about to
meet the new york society of architects
mathiel delgado award for excellence in
total design goes to Richie Espinosa
the American Institute of Architects
certificate and recognition of
scholastic achievement character and
promise of professional ability goes to
Andrew Seth McDowell
the American Institute of Architects
medal in recognition of scholastic
achievement character and promise of
professional ability goes to Troy
thirion
some honor awards for excellence in
design in recognition of the high
quality of work in the design students
during the students program of studies
there are a number of awards the first
is Otis Birkin
Zachary Colburn
Michael contento
Daniel Kidd
young yay Kim
Katie Shima
the Charles McKim prize for excellence
in design and the soul kaplan traveling
fellowship to recognize a student whose
work throughout the studio's has been
outstanding funded by a request from
Saul Kaplan who graduated 1957 this is a
prize for travel and study following
graduation the winner of this year's
McKim prizes Clinton Miller
we don't have any more prizes but I
would like you to award a prize to dr.
david hinkle who is the secret heart and
soul of the school
anybody who knows anything knows that
David is at once the most practical and
the most inspirational and intellectual
leader of our school and he's never ever
let a single person down in year after
year after year the amazing work that
you have done the amazing work that's on
all of the walls that you can see in
some way is to the credit of david
hinkle and his amazing team
so there's one more prize which is the
Percival Goodman award which is a
research award essentially for a project
which is seen to carry out the kind of
vision and way of thinking and
commitment to social justice of Percival
Goodman once on the faculty here and the
winner of the Percival Goodman award
this year is Troy
so the last word is something like well
from a practical point of view when we
go out I think there's like cakes and
chocolate and dessert sort of sweet
things so maybe the ending here is going
to be sweet for me personally amazingly
sweet to be with you I mean a very very
very somehow important year in which all
of us learned a lot and we primarily
learned it from the students the parents
and families who are in the room know
perfectly what I'm talking about you
know this kind of red-hot amazing
thirsty creative abilities of the people
that are sitting in these weird clothes
in front of you for us to get to know
those people that you've lived with your
whole life to take care a little bit of
them while they were here was an
enormous enormous privilege and so I
just want to thank the families and
maybe that's the last award should be
for everybody who came today and helped
us celebrate this amazing group
so one more time for the class of 2009
you